[Music]
[Applause]
oh baby oh my God the Garland or is this
just our new characters
welcome back to the break room everybody
it's the daily nerdy news show uh it
gives you everything you need to know
live from New rockstars actual Studios
our real break room here uh where we've
got some fun festive decorations we
might come back to that there there are
some details behind those later uh but
coming up on today's show uh Avatar with
the water is
good what
um why is Gamora and uh Bad Bad season
two First Look also a little bit of news
about The Flash movie and some other
things with me to discuss those topics
and more we've got Brandon Barrick
Jessica Clemens Tommy bechtold myself
Zach Huddleston we're all thrilled to be
here today
we hope you're uh excited to be here
with us I'm excited you know what I
can't up and feel it there's this
there's a little bit of a a special
feeling in the air bells are jingling
just a little bit more On Cue people are
smiling in a way that says we might be
on something and when you go to the mall
every single store has a message consume
obey they live it's Christmas they live
time yes it's always time for they live
hey uh let's hop into some headlines uh
We're not gonna have that graphic that's
okay I'm gonna give them a second no no
no no it's okay
um uh there oh there it is never mind
never doubt producer John
um avatar The Way of the water reviews
have started to trickle on the internet
and I believe that is trickle yeah pun
intended you're starting to Splash all
over the Internet
um believe that film is coming out
16th 16th a week from this Friday or
this weekend right
um and so the Embargo has been lifted
and people that have had a chance to see
it are starting to talk about it online
uh and the reviews are so far incredibly
positive uh you know we thought it would
be fun to play a little game with some
of these reviews yes okay okay I'm gonna
read a quote and we're gonna guess is
this a review for Avatar weight of the
water or is it reviews of Avatar themed
porn on Reddit oh good okay come on I'm
actually a pretty big Aficionado on one
of these guys okay and we'll leave that
up to the viewers
it's too early in the show for this
Behavior well uh hey it's a headline
um here here's a first quote the film is
visually breathtaking visceral and
Incredibly engrossing the story The
spectacle the spirituality the beauty
this is movie making and storytelling at
its absolute finest oh yeah that's that
that's from uh that's from have a hard
the spray of water I think it's porn
I think that one is legit actually I
don't have the answers to these producer
John does that's real okay great uh next
next quote hot oh that's a review of the
set
on Avatar was it warm while the lights
have you shot it down in New Zealand oh
that's the porn right John
okay that was the point okay all right
next question James Cameron once again
shows filmmakers how it's done I've said
it a thousand times never doubt him
porn no that's Avatar right now I could
see a world where eventually he's like I
don't like people making these without
me yeah I'm taking over the point it's
like it's well I'm sure the movie won't
bomb because if I like the movie then
people will laugh yes
that just came out today he's like I
know other people will like this movie
uh I can show them banging those whales
okay that was a real one uh here's
another one why is the picture just
shaking I think it's supposed to be one
of those
3D perspective pictures
that's gotta be the
yeah John is at the point okay that is
the port that is the point uh Avatar the
way of water LOL imagine being dumb
enough to bet against James Cameron or
teen alien Sigourney Weaver or giant
whales subtitled in Papyrus light years
better than the first and easily one of
the best theatrical experiences in ages
streaming found dead in a ditch I was uh
not exactly champping at the bit for an
avatar too even if James Cameron plus
wet tends to work out pretty well at
least now I can't wait to see Avatar 3.
that's basically all I wanted out of
this and it delivered in a big way uh
okay well first of all whoever wrote
that should be behind bars John is that
your personal review of the film
oh that's from producer John himself I
do wonder if James Cameron was at this
screening just like eyeing everyone down
and watching them or maybe it was like a
saw a scenario where you put on once you
put on the glasses like they wouldn't
come back
positively I mean you can see 10 000
words positive about this movie before
these glasses or they'll explode and
before we get to the last one again for
context anytime this often the early
reviews on Twitter are going to be
overwhelmingly right sure sure people
that got to see the movie early
um they also can't really they can't get
any detail so it's much easier to be a
fusive and praised and be like it's bad
but I don't want to tell you why yes and
they're Limited in the their words and
things like that so uh often they're
positive but it is these are pretty
overwhelming and some people are heaping
some pretty big Praise on this film uh
finally does anyone else find this
weirdly unsettling
I mean that could be both that could I
could I'm actually gonna say earnestly
that is the the way up water it could be
both I'm gonna go porn John
that was the point that was the point do
you do do each of you think this movie
will make over a billion dollars like
it's predecessor I do well it does it
again for context wakanda forever has
already made 700 million worldwide I
believe it was well on its way to 800.
so like you know this movie would need
to do better than wakanda forever
significantly better but you know Maybe
I don't know I think the navier global
brand you know I think Avatar is a
global brand much like Transformers I
yeah I think this movie cruises past the
billion oh okay okay I mean some people
have pointed out like it's uh many years
later since the 15 years later since the
first one yeah uh uh and movie ticket
prices are a little higher so that will
bump it a little bit oh my Glacier will
bump it a little bit uh Avatar Land in
Disney is five years old now so we have
five years of kids going to Disney World
and seeing that world and only having
that one piece of property to reference
to it so now they have another movie I
mean like I don't know a big part of me
as a kid but went to Disney World and
wanted to see all the things yeah that
the the right who is this Mr Toad and
how can I consume his content I need to
get on his Wild Ride okay and we're
excited for that we're going to be
seeing it uh I'm a little concerned
about that three hour plus run time yeah
we handle that water I'm gonna have to
pee so much water well we are going to
deliver to you as soon as we've seen it
here at the break room we will tell you
the best bathroom break scenes okay we
will deliver the definitive guide on
when you can go to the bathroom and
never forget the bechtold method by
about 100 feet of garden hose and run a
thing out the fire exit
can you piss in a theater through a
garden hose don't demonetize us
other headlines
um The Flash movie release date has been
moved up one week uh the movie is now
going to be released on June 16th 2023
next year um it was said to be released
on the 23rd uh but they're kind of
getting it out of the way of Indiana
Jones 5 which is coming out the
following week that's June 30th they got
scared right yes and you know Jones five
Studios often do this they basically
want like flash to be the biggest movie
at theaters for two weeks now instead of
just one week you want to be able to put
on the the
TV spot the number one movie in America
is still the flash I think even after
Indiana Jones Come Out they'll still say
the number one speed force yeah yes the
number one meta human yeah yes yeah and
hey we like them being spaced out
because it gives us more stuff to talk
about exactly and and you know we've
said before the by all accounts the
reviews the test screenings of The Flash
movie I know it's a cliche now in the
comic book world news it does appear to
be testing very well as evidenced by
they're willing to you know kind of Wade
through controversial Waters to even get
the movie put out so yeah it's a pretty
good sign that that movie's going to be
a hit for DC and we hope it's great yeah
we're rooting for it
um a trailer for the second season of
the bad batch was released today a
little two minute uh teaser for what's
coming on Disney plus the series will
begin streaming on January 4th 2023
pretty soon yeah less than a month away
you've got time to watch season one if
you're one of those haters that doesn't
watch The Animated stuff I mean I I've
been I've been guilty of that myself
I've been guilty of ignoring the Clone
Wars turning my back Rebels and Rebels
uh ignoring resistance even existence so
for bad batch at least if you want to
limit yourself to that you only have one
season you have to catch up
yeah yeah
um and that season's on Disney plus
which we know you all subscribe to uh
because why wouldn't you at this point
well one of you has hacked into mind
because every time I turn it on it's in
French and Chinese subtitles so whoever
did that Mazel Tov could this be an
inside job is there somebody in your
family who speaks French and Chinese uh
maybe I don't know we're pretty smart in
the back told family I'm you know you
came up with that whole garden host
thing right it's fairly genius and I'd
love to say it was me who came up with
that method but that was grandpappy back
told yeah God knows himself if you know
what I mean anyway back to the show okay
so real quick we want to plug uh this
week you know you see our lovely
decorations we're celebrating the
holidays this week Friday on Friday's
episode of the break room we're gonna
have our our first annual break room
holiday party yeah that's right uh the
show will be celebrating during it and
those celebrations will be brought to
you by our good friends at iconic
cocktails and go grab one of your
wonderful proud right here iconic
cocktails makes these uh fancy cocktail
mixers like this bitter orange tonic
that we're going to be using to make a
delicious batch cocktail on Friday we
have posted um some recipes I think in
the description of this video
um you can follow along if you've
already ordered some iconic cocktail
mixers you can make the exact same
drinks we make yeah on on Friday and
drink along with us Tommy will be doing
his best uh bartending work
shake shake shake poor poor poor strain
strain strain stir stir stir kick the
drunk out of the bar kick the drunk out
of the bar slide your phone number to
the pretty girl take the phone number
from the ugly girl rip it up throw it in
the trash tape it together when you're
feeling sad call her up start a
relationship shake shake shake poor poor
poor repeat the process till you die
that's a bartender's life okay okay all
right yeah so we'll be making uh two
different cocktails on Friday uh
sorry I caught a cocktails I owe you one
on that I don't know I think uh
um uh we're making a Quantum Manhattan
uh a Manhattan cocktail inspired by
quantumania and with um their cranberry
thyme uh syrup from Iconic cocktails and
we'll be making a um nowhere to go a
mocktail which is nice thing about
iconic cocktails uh these things you can
mix with non-alcoholic beverages do it
all the time coffee they're vanilla
mixer I put it with my coffee I know I'm
sounding like a broken record here two
slow spoonfuls takes your coffee from
ironic to iconic ooh what a nice way to
put it and yeah the The Road to Nowhere
uh or nowhere to go I apologize will be
um a mocktail based in on T and they're
a bit of orange tonic so it's a nice
thing for folks that don't feel like
drinking or if you want to mix and match
I always say a good native drinking
maybe this is good advice if you have
some holiday parties to attend in Europe
drinking age
um go back and forth have an alcoholic
beverage but in between each alcoholic
beverage have a non-alcohol yeah you
know we call that the water the water
system where I'm from you know you water
you drink one water to every drink and
suddenly you find yourself not
regretting everything you did the night
before yes I do I do spicy Margarita
chocolate milkshake spicy Margarita
chocolate milkshake yeah but you do
novelty sizes of both oh yeah so you
have like a giant margarita glass and
like a just a pitcher of milk oh yeah
yeah yeah I ordered a picture of red
blonde vodkas from a bar once and they
gave it to me
this makes it great
um a great gift right that's the holiday
gift giving season maybe you have a
friend in your life that likes uh
cocktails uh maybe you sometimes go out
to bars with them and they order fancy
drinks but this is nice they can make
those fancy drinks at home uh they've
got some great like uh combo kit like
kind of gifts gift sets and stuff like
that head to iconic cocktail.com use our
promo code it's on screen right now new
rockstars you get 20 off your order uh
again that's iconic cocktail.com they've
got recipes all kinds of great
information uh to help you be a
bartender on the order of Tommy bechtold
minus the necessary failed relationship
and also you said it before but just a
reminder you can get our recipes in the
description of this video don't be like
me and try and wing it you know what one
of the reasons I've worked at so many
bars is because in my early days you'd
ask me for a drink I serve whatever I
thought it was then I read the
bartender's Bible and much like people
read the real Bible it'll come to Jesus
moment but my Jesus was a man named
Jameson anyway moving on moving how do
those Guardians meet up with Gamora
in between the sadness in between the
The Joy uh that's a great question Tommy
one thing we want to talk about today is
we keep dissecting this Guardians of the
Galaxy vol 3 trailer uh one of the
things we haven't really discussed much
is our good green gal Gomorrah right
jolly green gal the Jolly the jolly
green gal uh she shows up in this movie
again uh but this is a different Gamora
we gotta remember that because the
Gamora 616 that we used to know uh she's
dead she died she got thrown off a cliff
uh by her adopted father Thanos adopted
so is this a Gamora variant because it
isn't a 616 Gamora it's still 616 good
morning I guess in a lot of ways it is
but I think the TVA would consider this
uh a branch timeline yeah like a variant
that needs to be destroyed like pruned
because she was taken out of her time
but cba's done uh or it's different now
uh so the the Gamora that we knew we saw
the character development with she died
she is at the bottom of warmer she's
Crow food I don't know if they've got
crows Crow food yeah they're gonna eat
her they're carrions they eat uh that
stuff uh so in in Game of course we we
got a new Gamora who came to the present
day with Thanos who uh kind of came
through the little Time Tunnel uh and
this camera has no idea who the
guardians are she hasn't met them yet
she's from 2014 right uh so we could
think of this Gamora as like a
completely new character uh that will
need to be reintroduced or introduced to
the first time with the Guardians of the
Galaxy even though they know her and
they think they know her uh they don't
even really know who she is and even
like nebula who killed herself who
killed the past version of herself she
doesn't even really know this Gamora she
knew her at one point but now this
Gamora has had some new experiences that
nebula has no uh interaction with and so
nebula is kind of meeting her for the
first time too uh in some of the
Comic-Con footage that was shown at San
Diego back this past summer the
Guardians first meet up with Gamora when
their ship gets boarded by a group of
ravagers after saying they have quote an
appointment with Gamora quiltos Gamora
he loves her and she says that person
wasn't me this happened in footage that
was shown at Comic-Con uh that we heard
about we didn't really get to see it but
it seems like from that Comic-Con
footage nebula is the one that found a
way to get in touch with Gamora or like
set up this appointment uh and our
thinking is that after Adam Warlock
attacks nowhere that seems like that
might but what might be happening here
the Guardians need information and help
and they turn to the ravagers the only
other people in the Galaxy that they can
turn to right this group that has a lot
of ties to them uh via craglin VIA quill
they have a history with the ravagers
but it also seems like
Gamora because in that footage she's
wearing a ravager suit so it's not even
like she's just hanging with the
ravagers she probably has taken them
over because she's a very driven
individual she is a sect of them or a
group of them under her leadership
because this Gamora was like working
with Thanos and I say working with with
loose terms because we even know in the
first Guardian she was not really
aligned with thanos's Mission she was
like kind of scared of him couldn't
really run away and was working with him
but was also like I found the Soul Stone
but I'm never gonna tell him where it is
uh so she she was already branching away
from Thanos but the type of stuff she
does is the kind of stuff that like the
ravagers like to do right they like to
pillage they like to attack they like to
take what's theirs so it makes sense
that she's kind of running with the
ravagers yeah and I also think
um because Gamora I think me and Mt were
talking about this earlier today how
Gamora uh there was just like this
timeline of how Gamora worked and how
she found on like how she got empathy
and like was a nice person and I think
that's when she hit prison and met the
other part of the
um Guardians of the Galaxy so it's like
this one never went to prison possibly
but also I still think both of them
ultimately are striving for a family
connection because they didn't have that
same family that they had before so
where this new Gamora doesn't have the
guardian she's making her family out of
the ravagers and so I think instead of
her taking it over it's more so like
this is because they are family the
ravagers especially after the second
Guardians of the Galaxy when they split
into like sides and sections so I think
this is like they see her as like a
sister they see her as like a mom or
they see her as just like a family
member versus a leader like when Wendy
when the last one they're like we need a
mother you be our mother and she's like
I'll cut your balls off uh I'm not your
mother I think James Gunn is doing that
yeah he's taking that storyline and
turning her into Wendy and little that's
that's very insightful because this
Gamora while she's different from the
Gomorrah we knew she has the same past
and that's a very insightful thing to
say that like Gamora is striving for our
family that she doesn't have she has the
family she was forced into but her
family is taken away from her when she
was a child and so yes she wants a
family and maybe you know we see an end
game but she's like I don't know you
guys I'm out of here bye-bye she doesn't
like the family that the people trying
to pull her this is like she's like I
don't want this is like another family
forcing themselves right right like
Thanos did right do you think Thanos
ever took her on vacation when she was a
kid like he was like all right I've been
doing a lot of universe elimination
let's take you to uh to Zanzibar I think
that was the vacation is going to like
xandar or whatever or where the plan
that he did destroy being like isn't
this beautiful give me a second
I think that's totally it like it's like
a fake vacation he's like oh don't worry
we're going on vacation and they're like
sitting at a restaurant he's looking
around he's like there's too many
waiters at this restaurant his
his ship must have had like a pool yeah
right like there was probably a game
room somewhere on that [ __ ] because he
didn't seemed like he wanted her to be
miserable right like you so he wants
nebula to be missing right yeah it's an
emulate for some reason um there's
always One in Every Family yeah I I love
all those points you just made I think
that family connection's such an
interesting one right like also she's a
woman who's like kind of not had as much
agency as she probably wanted in her
life right especially under the thumb of
like this giant dictator kind of power
mad Titan guy right she's not going on
dates yeah and like the cool thing about
being a ravager especially if you're a
leader of a ravager like they're pretty
free people right like they don't really
answer to any government or or any like
greater power necessarily right they're
kind of loose wild cards well I got this
dumb code they have to follow where they
can't kidnap children it's a dumb code
wait wait until you got mad at you
because they kidnapped kids well that's
oh no go go no I was gonna say do you
think that's a dumb code or do you think
you know if branding the person or
there's extra kids running around just
snatch one off the street okay that was
that an extra kid
wow yeah well it was an orphan yeah yeah
this also wasn't gamora's first time
being a ravager technically oh is that
sound tell us Jessica after you're done
carving out a mosaic on the table you
guys know I need to fiddle with things
and I don't have anything these are
expensive tablecloths I know they are
they cost 3.99
that is pretty pricey for tables all
right go on um
so in the comics there's an early run of
comic books that are actually the
Captain Marvel comic book line where
it's a different planet uh different
Universe it's like Earth two five seven
something something there's a bunch of
numbers
um where
Star-Lord is Lord star kill and he leads
the ravagers that are the Guardians of
the Galaxy and Gamora is the one that's
like we need to overthrow this guy he's
a he's a problem she runs the museums
basically because he so yeah on Stark
Hill because he basically was like
um hey he went up to this in this
universe this planet Thanos is actually
a peacekeeper he is not a bad guy he's
like I only want Justice for everything
and all he sees the ravagers are a bunch
of pirates and so he's like hey star
kill I'm gonna take you guys in and
start goes like I'll give you my team if
you let me survive and then Carol
Danvers was running the opposite team
and they were like yo we don't like
Carol Danvers so Gamora was like one we
all do a mutiny and turn them both in
and then also was like okay thanks for
turning them in now I'm gonna wipe every
pirate out and they fight and Gamora is
basically leading and I think that's a
good thing to take away from uh for the
next Guardians because it's like again
what I said about family I think we'll
just have like a really consciously good
actual Gamora just for the ravagers kind
of like in what if what we saw with
t'challa as the ravager I think it's
like this rabbit this Gamora is gonna
align people correctly in the ravagers
and I think that James Gunn is just
gonna take from that storyline from the
comic book just to replace Gamora in
this storyline I feel like it's easier
anyway it's already written I like it
it's interesting because like
technically can you have an ethical
pirate can you have a good benevolent
pirate
Robin Hood uh so are they only gonna Rob
Rich uh planets and spaceships well
pirates in in our land the pirates that
we know the the Buccaneers uh they were
originally like contracted out they had
like legal precedent to be Pirates uh
from the British government well that
was as long as they only robbed the
attackers
the red pirate Roberts famously only
mythologically evil but I but is
actually a nice person according to the
film The Princess Bride yeah Gary the
happy pirate a popular children's
musician in Rochester New York never
seen him do a bad thing I heard he takes
kids off the streets are kids we do not
speak ill of Gary on this show Gary the
happy pirate is a treasure I don't think
that uh she'll be like great I don't
think they're to be fair in the MCU I
don't think there is such a thing as
good I think everyone's the lesser of
two evils uh because we have Vigilantes
and Vigilantes are not always correct so
I think it's just making the ravages
from what the worst part of what they
were to a better version of the
themselves and maybe it's that like even
like no kidnapping kids or maybe just
like if we're pillaging we're not
pillaging planters that are like Refugee
planets like we're not going for those
like I think it's maybe going that way
because Gamora is still Gamora even
though it's a new Gamora it's like she's
gonna find that right alignment soon it
just has it's like Who's Gonna Knock it
into her yeah and like we've seen we
know like hopefully most of the ravagers
we recognize are currently living on
nowhere yes right as of the Guardians
holiday special kind of colonizing that
they're a little less wandering the
universe kind of a deal seems like they
found a home but like we're assuming she
is with a group of ravagers that is not
going to be hanging out of nowhere still
off planet do we think Adam Warlock is
going to conquer nowhere like is that
going to be like the Guardians will
become displaced once again I think he's
just there to kill them and like if
they're not there he doesn't want to be
you know he's just going after this so
they have to escape nowhere and then
he's giving Chase yeah because his his
mommy Aisha is like go kill these these
Guardians yeah he's like yes Mommy I'll
do it for you I hope that Gamora and
Peter don't wind up together at the end
of this I don't think they will I told
you this I think we talked about it on
the break room I was like oh okay I
think we did bring this up on the break
room or at least I did where I was like
I think if they're open then we have
kitty Pride coming in the future for
Star-Lord and then we'll have Gamora
finding Adam Warlock really attractive
because Adam Warlock is the ultimate
being and is very strong and this now
Gamora is probably like no Peter Quill
you're weak as hell look at you man
you're just a a boy man and then she's
gonna look at star or look at Adam
Warlock and be like no that's a man
that's a gold man but Star Wars gonna
die in this movie that's always not
who's gonna die Tommy ain't nobody dying
in Phase five oh they wait nobody
what about Cosmo of the dog no I've
turned it around okay Cosmo the dog is
going to live in yeah
they're playing Cosmo the dog will die
by my hair oh no worries
oh the actual CGI dog yeah yeah yeah no
that's a human it's a mo-capped human is
that Andy Circus crawling around on all
fours I think it's Andy jerkis from
those Avatar boards oh my gosh don't
give him the time yes I was gonna make a
Sigourney Weaver uh porn punch it's a
gorgeous Wiener that's a good one that's
a good one I was just gonna go beaver
but uh oh that still works gorgeous
wieners to call back to John and I and
forget who else
did you get it I thought we were just
all going off of important names I'm not
I'm not participating Sam gerthing
that's what I was yeah I was trying to
get a Sam one what's the what's the guy
who plays Stephen Lang Stephen Lang yeah
blowey zaldana
hey Joey come on yeah all right listen
it's time for mandatory fun
oh thank goodness
it's time for mandatory fun the segment
so successful that we only run it once
or twice a week
again
yes listen to me you simp if you haven't
liked this video And subscribe to our
Channel yeah you're absolutely dead to
me at Christmas time hey somehow you got
Wi-Fi in your dumpsters which is truly
an incredible achievement Kate skinslit
yes is she an advertisinger yeah dude
she learned to hold her breath for like
10 minutes oh he actually did not for
Avatar though jerk main Clement uh now
you said my name Gucci Mane all right
all right now
uh actually I did you guys a little
solid last oh okay I snuck into the
writer's Guild of America wow
I broke in after hours and I stole some
scripts some scripts to some upcoming
movies oh wow I stole a script from
Avatar the way of water heard of it I
stole a script from The Flash oh the
flesh no The Flash I heard the flesh The
Flash I stole a script from Guardians of
the Galaxy Vol 3. oh okay and I stole a
script from Ant-Man quantumania wow I
stole four scripts and for mandatory fun
you guys are going to read them
unfortunately
no I can't no Tommy Tommy I have some
big news Dr nasty has gotten a hold of
some emu shins and I'm finally gonna get
those shins they have a lot of [ __ ] I've
been wanting those [ __ ] exactly forever
so Dr nasty is going to put those shims
in also I think emu Shin I think yeah
she co-started yeah
cause it's just emotions taking me over
all right listen I can't be here Dr
Nancy's gonna go to work on me I did
find someone to take over if you guys
could just tell the camera what you want
for Christmas well I go get our sub host
yeah what do you want for Christmas
Jessica
um
did a lot of things I want I want my
parents to get back together oh I like
my parents apart you're Brandon have
your parents been divorced for like 30
years yeah and they both have already
remarried but who knows maybe it could
work out huh see my mom a villain
slithers towards his maniacal perch that
is i t Michael Shakespeare told
a master thespian oh okay a man who
Treads the bullets with a plum and
Applause a man who's no stranger to the
hardwood and the hard wood if you catch
my drift oh let us read from these
Scripts
some of these appear to not be scripts
at all they're just written stories Zach
please will you oh regardless with the
towel of a Speedster the fastest man on
earth okay yeah it looks like it's
mostly just stage description uh the
flash walks into a McDonald's and makes
a beeline for the counter he orders a
Big Mac only to find out that it's not
available at this particular restaurant
suddenly if this McDonald's doesn't have
a Big Mac that's right at this
particular McDonald's suddenly he hears
a familiar voice behind him he turns and
sees a high school mascot a cougar
standing in the corner of the restaurant
the NASCAR glares it flash mocking him
and accusing him of not being able to
order what he wanted the Flash doesn't
take kindly to this jeering and soon the
two are engaged in a heated Exchange
the mascot continues to mock flash while
flash retorts that he could take on the
mascot any day the mascot eager to prove
his superiority gets up close to flash
and Taps him on the shoulder that's when
all hell breaks
Flash rushes the mascot and the two of
them battle it out no mention of flash
being fast at all this is merely a
segment of the scripts my cousin stole
from The Writer's Guild West the uh the
two of them Babble it out a mix amidst
the shocked patrons and employees
cheeseburgers and fries go flying and it
looks like the mascot is dominating the
fight wow
this is this is what I also like this
it's not in any kind of script format he
just sentences I
guess as it seems like the mascot will
prevail flash summons is super human
speed okay and lays down some impressive
blows eventually defeating the mask
impressive blows that's one of the
reviews for The Avatar forms
the now humbled mascot slinks away
leaving flash to bask in his victory he
orders a new big match and Savers every
bite wait now it's available at the
restaurant yes a confounding bit of
prose from an artificial intelligence
machine
oh oh like these scripts could have been
written by AI okay
um is that how all Hollywood
Blockbusters are being made now I will
never reveal the secrets of the Silver
Screen put a little birdie told me right
now they're just entering prompts into
computers and letting anything that
shits out of on the big screen oh
interesting now team Michael's
Shakespeare old T Michael Shakespeare
tools team Michael string Spirit told
excuse me yeah you prefer scripts that
are in I am
that's right that's 15 syllables no
rhyming uh some sort of bodily sound in
every like a gurgle or a churlish
all right
hey at least one of those sounds I think
the Wired Magazine review of that live
magazine called Avatar the way of water
I Triumph of Cinema okay do not miss
this film oh okay all right Jessica will
you read this speaking of Avatar away of
water script you'll be playing
I'll be playing a surprise character
okay
do you want me to read this part no uh
no you can ignore the part that we do
yeah oh yes please Brandon scene a a
lush jungle Planet a group of Navi
Warriors led by the shaman omitakaya
stands atop a ridge looking down at a
group of Wookies omotakaya steps forward
Welcome to our planet we are the navi
people
foreign
I Am The Wookie it is an honor to meet
you it is an honor to meet you too we
have heard stories of your courage and
strength we've heard stories of your
wisdom and nippleless bodies we would we
would like to form a bond with you will
you link with us let's link do what I do
we will link with you the navian wookies
join hands forming a circle of
connection and friendship as they do the
planet around them is imbued with a new
sense of unity and understanding we have
formed a sacred bond with the wookies
and together we will stand strong in our
common mission
and see wow truly Avatar will take us
places we never dreamed possibly I think
the navi would be very attracted to the
wookies because of all that hair yeah
big contrast
truly hopefully we get an answer to what
that hair do in this film
I will now read
saving the best for last okay thank you
a scene from Guardians of the Galaxy vol
3. fade in exterior space heard of it
day
we see the Guardians of the Galaxy
flying in the ship the Milano music
plays as the team is excited about their
mission they're back in the Milano
exterior Planet surface a day aren't
they in the Bowie now the Guardians of
the Galaxy land on a strange planet
known as counter Earth hmm exterior
Planet surface heard of it day the
Guardians of the Galaxy explore the
planet meeting some of its inhabitants
the inhabitants are initially cautious
of the Guardians of the Galaxy but
eventually come around when they realize
the Guardians are here to help the
inhabitants you know the AI is not very
exciting
an average explained to the Guardians
how their planet is being threatened by
a group of powerful forces
my God is this Terence Valley
they offer to assist the Guardians and
find a way to stop them the Guardians I
think I'm just going to skip ahead
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
it's not that difficult it's not that
hard it's paper he's fine I'd rather
have t Michael Marlow here than T
Michael Shakespeare told me
Michael Brett
uh okay so this is a scene that Tommy
stole from the WG West you want to be
that character yeah okay uh that's from
uh amber on the WASP quantumanium uh
I'll I'll read some State Direction okay
Janet Van Dyne steps into an the empty
restaurant and remembers the last time
she was here she's in the quantum realm
at this point 30 years ago she and Bill
Murray had sex in the back Booth I guess
he's playing himself yeah I guess today
she hopes he'll show show what I think
just show up oh okay got it Janet takes
a seat and orders a drink she hopes
he'll show probably full dog he's
already done that and he's being
canceled
ding dong bills back
foreign takes a seat in order to drink
suddenly the door
Rex Open Bill stands at me Bill stands
at the entrance looking around
hesitantly Janet Janet gets up walking
towards him as they stand looking at
each other in disbelief bill
they Embrace in a warm hug I can't
believe you're here build gestures for
her to take a seat it's been a long time
they sit across from each other rarely
studying each other's changes over 30
years I'm sorry for the way things ended
it doesn't matter now I made a huge
mistake we were so young but we had a
lot of fun I know I think about it all
the time they sit in comfortable silence
for a few moments remembering so what
have you been up to oh this and that I
got married had a couple kids started my
own business you I became a doctor
apparently I'm good at that
they reminisce and discuss the changes
in their lives they look out the window
at the Starlet night sky and feel a deep
connection the night ends with a gentle
hug and a promise of reunion in another
30 years
a doctor thrilling
thrilling outcomes for all four
certainly if these are things to come
for the Cinematic slate ahead of us
naps will be abundant in the next few
years snooze is all snoozes and losers I
forecast I don't think each of these
four movies will make a hundred dollars
at the box office and I'm never wrong
quotes
The Raven whoa never wrong never wrong
yes that was T my goal Beck Shakespeare
Ted gurg Allen Bo wow
again we though we thought those were
stolen from the wga they might have been
someone from the wga AI prompt WTA they
sometimes used to help write
Blockbusters we'll never know
um hopefully the the films are much
better than those scenes made them out
to be
um
emotions they only had actions so now I
have tiny Shins
it feels like no shins at all oh it's
like to be a Shameless like the grandpa
from King of the Hill that is uh yeah
um hey we think you all uh for watching
along with us today uh we've got some
really fun stuff coming out on the
channel of course you should check out
Tommy and Jessica's Transformers right
as the Beast breakdown that came out
yesterday uh the roof Anna has a a
second uh Mario trailer breakdown that's
out on the channel right now and Eric
Voss has a Last of Us
it's him oh
that's pants Labyrinth I'm a clicker oh
oh he's a clicker it's the last of us
thing
yeah yeah yeah okay a rare boss sighting
hey come on hit that like button yeah
hit that like button subscribe
um and check out all those in other
great videos we've got some other great
uh Guardians of the Galaxy videos that
are out on the channel now and are
coming out soon a lot of cool content
and again come back uh come back every
day it says you come back Friday for our
holiday party okay we did get some super
Chatters and I it's hard to figure out
who did so we just want to give a
general thank you to anyone who said in
this super chat today we're having a
little technical malfunction we're not
100 able to identify who you are we will
figure it out uh and I will probably do
my evening prayers thank you straight
from my Lord and Savior thank you Josh
Allen oh yes
um uh but we we thank you so much for
watching we hope you have a great rest
of your evening and a great rest of your
week
goodbye everyone
[Music]
thank you
[Music]